Вітрильний спорт пов'язаний з природою,
бо ти постійно на природі,
на свіжому повітрі, на воді.
Людина починає розуміти,
що є обставини непереборної сили.
З вітром можна тільки співпрацювати.
Перемагати його ніколи не можна,
його ніколи не переможеш.
Можу вам сказати, що, коли виходжу на вулицю
і є вітер, я себе відчуваю вільною людиною.
І вітер надихає.
Це вітрильна яхта, круїзна.
Вона досить легка в управлінні.
Початківець, маючи певні навички,
може спокійно і безпечно на ній ходити.
На цій яхті два паруси.
Це називається грот, він зараз у нас у сумці лежить,
і передній парус називається стаксель.
Максимальна швидкість,
яка була зафіксована на цій яхті, — сім вузлів.
Це приблизно 13–14 км/год.
Яхта обладнана спеціальними відсіками,
які не дозволяють її потопити.
Вони герметичні.
Тобто навіть якщо туди прибуває вода —
яхта не одразу почне тонути.
Прийшов до нас у школу якийсь тренер і сказав:
«А може, ви будете займатися
морським багатоборством? Це дуже цікаво!».
І я пішов.
Потім почав змагатися на крейсерських яхтах.
Пізніше вояжі робив,
а потім далі-далі-далі й мене обрали
віцепрезидентом Вітрильної федерації України.
Вже другий термін.
Тобто в мене все життя
з 1971 року пов’язане з вітрильництвом.
Займаюся зараз розвитком власної
чартерної компанії в Києві, в Україні,
для того, щоб організовувати
тури по Дніпру на яхтах.
У 2009 році на туристичній виставці
познайомився з одним поляком, який сказав:
«Слухай, це дуже просто! Поїхали в Хорватію,
я тебе швидко навчу, і за тиждень отримаєш права».
Так і сталося.
Тому що в нас були інші традиції, радянські.
Тобі весь час втовкмачували: «Ні, це дуже довго!
Ти повинен роками вчитися, виходити».
Це не складніше, ніж їздити на машині.
Тому минулого року ми купили яхту
спеціально, щоб розвивати такий бізнес в Україні.
Коли ми йдемо в перегони,
в нас є, по-перше, обставини,
на які ми не можемо впливати, — це вітер, течія, хвиля.
От ми йдемо і на деякому відрізку дистанції можемо
співпрацювати з кимось проти іншого,
бо кожен хоче бути першим.
Але через декілька відрізків
дистанції все може помінятися.
З ким співпрацював, я вже буду змагатися.
Це йде в рамках правил,
безумовно, це спортивна боротьба.
Я коли йду десь, то завжди
шукаю з ким би позмагатися.
Все життя на дистанції.
Тобто я хочу і в справі,
і вдома бути найкращим.
Київські яхти ходили й навколо світу,
і доходили до Мису Хорн.
Мис Хорн — це Південна Америка,
і вважається Еверестом яхтингу.
Традиція ось таких круїзних яхт
у нас зараз продовжується.
Є такий Київський крейсерський
міський яхт-клуб, або скорочено КРЯК.
Йому приблизно понад 50 років.
І більшість яхт, які зроблені там,
зроблені самотужки.
Є спортивні яхти для перегонів,
на яких вчаться буквально
із семи років діти й виростають чемпіонами.
Так от, у нас у Києві був такий
легендарний чемпіон Валентин Манкін.
Він трикратний олімпійський чемпіон,
до того ж у різних класах.
Це унікально!
Рекорд у світі.
Це, мабуть, найвидатніший
вітрильник України й світу,
бо ніхто не може повторити
його досягнення й по сьогодні.
Це мій наставник,
за яким я прийшов у вітрильництво.
Прийшов хлопчиком,
і стільки років я у вітрильництві.
Бо вітрильництво — це не лише
спортивні досягнення, це лінія життя.
Процедура старту на загальний старт, п'ятихвилинка.
П'ять — Індія,
чотири — Папа,
за хвилину Папа прибирається,
старт, прибирається.
Це буде супроводжуватися сигналом.
Бажаю всім натхнення, успіхів і вдалого старту!
Ці прапори означають якусь літеру.
С — Сієра, він завжди Сієра.
Знак I — це Індія.
Зазвичай усі регати
розпочинаються з реєстрації.
Суддівське судно виходить
і виставляє стартову лінію.
Сьогодні в нас буде дві дистанції на підвітряній.
Тобто старт іде проти вітру.
Й одна буде маршрутна.
Вона йтиме до київського крейсерського яхт-клубу.
А потім, на фініші, кожне судно
реєструється із часом проходження дистанції.
— Добрий день!
— Добрий.
— Як ви тут поживаєте?
— Не дочекаєтеся.
Вітрила, тенти для яхт, для катерів.
Тобто ви робите тканинні конструкції,
але насамперед вітрила.
Вітрила, так, ми із цього розпочинали,
а тенти підійшли пізніше.
А ви шиєте їх на машинках чи як?
У комп'ютері проєктуємо, потім вона кроїться
на плотері й після цього збирається.
Вітрильництвом я почав займатись 1968 року,
але вже серйозніше шити вітрила
з початком 1990-х років.
Мені допомагали тоді західні журнали з яхтингу.
Там можна було подивитися вітрила,
як вони там стоять залежно.
Через лупу стояли дивилися,
розглядали ці фотографії,
щоб якось застосувати тут.
Сам беру участь у перегонах
і ходжу, ніхто не заважає. Так добре.
Сам віддав собі команду,
сам пішов зробив.  Все, так добре, чудово!
Коли зайві люди є, то кажеш,
а вони не знають, що робити.
А тут сказав і знаєш, що робити.
Теж прикольно.
Стратегія, техніка і тактика —
це дуже притаманно вітрильному спорту.
Люди, яких з дитинства виховували в цій царині,
в цьому середовищі мають
досить твердий характер вдачі.
Вітрильний спорт — це шахи на воді.
Кожен рух — не простий:
ти обираєш коли йти,
коли зробити поворот,
бо дивишся на своїх суперників,
на течію, на вітер.
Вітер ж не дує однаково.
За п'ять метрів там інший вітер.
Ми всі бачимо вітер.
Ті, хто змагаються, під вітрилами ходять,
по воді бачуть, де вітер є, де немає.
Вийшовши за межі Києва,
ти потрапляєш в абсолютно інший світ.
В дуже класний, красивий, несподіваний.
Більшість киян чи жителів міст не уявляє,
які в нас є колосальні можливості на Дніпрі.
Бухточки, острівці, заплави.
Ти потрапляєш по суті в заповідник.
На мою думку, оця дикість у нас —
наша найбільша перевага.
Треба сюди людей затягнути, показати, що це є.
На цій акваторії має бути принаймні в 50 разів більше яхт одночасно, тому що вона дозволяє це зробити.
Вітрильництво — як наркотик.
Це один раз спробував, сподобалося і все.
І далі ти вже не можеш.
Кинув, декілька років не приходив, а потім побачив і знову побіг.
Це вже така форма життя, мабуть, у людей.
Свобода.
Різноманітні пригоди.
Романтика.